hey nice to meet you finally there we go
east coast Eddie makuu from gamespot
Boston we actually have an office there
really is just you though right no
there's a like five ten other people
from cnet mostly yeah yeah repin it you
are the creator of basically most of the
articles on gamespot com and we never
get the hang out so it is great to have
you in time for GDC thank you it's great
to be here there are some news I hear
some things have happened yes I hear I
hear the sims finally got fixed unsold
of diablo in the exact same day Simpsons
SimCity Simpson is senior real newsman
O'Dwyer SimCity has an offline mode now
that's the big news for it long long
awaited much requested feature it as its
name suggests lets you play the game
offline which was people have been
clamoring for since they won because
that's you know you know the game was
terribly it would just had a terrible
launch cameras were down no one could
play it again and then it took them they
said in January they're going to
eventually make it so that you could
play offline i remember in like the week
preceding the game's launch somebody
hacked us and basically managed to make
in an offline mode right Maxis had said
that you know it would not be
technologically impossible but they said
to be you know require a ton of
engineering expertise and skill and it
sounded like something that they weren't
going to do yeah and then when they
finally announced it fans are really
happy I mean we'll see how it's received
now Mina can imagine there'd be like any
more issues cuz ya offline you really
think there's gonna be people who are
like waiting to purchases that are now
going to get it or is this more service
to the people who won't even it's
probably just fanservice you know this
is something that people had wanted for
a long time so delivering it and trying
to win back some of that lost goodwill I
think is going to be helpful for them
speaking of games being sold Walmart
Barney's getting into the use game
straight yeah they are taking gamestop
head-on which is oh my big news gamestop
you know they've had a lot of
competitors in the past target best buy
even walmart launched a pilot program in
2009 yeah but all of them failed no one
can eat away at games game stops market
share so far but Walmart largest
retailer in the world they're starting
this program 3100 stores nationwide
March 26 trade in your games all games
no hardware though so they'll get a
differentiator is that is that just for
the start or is that going to be
continuing thing you know we talked with
a Walmart
marketing chief on Monday and he said
well he didn't give any information
about that and he sounded pretty you
know black and white about there's not
going to be any hardware involved with
this and gamestop shares are down today
50 really so market got a little jittery
they're like good Walmart's coming after
you Oh snack like I mean because Walmart
is enjoy Norma's yeah yeah like all
across the country yeah yeah and they
said you know another big differentiator
there is you can only get a store credit
but okay walmart sells food and padding
so you can trade in your games for
clothing which is something or food that
gamestop cannot offer we should do a
feature where we see how many sucks we
can buy for a copy of to human to visit
the new games law rating scale yeah food
is like how many boxes of cheezits yeah
you can get for just dance for ya cuz
then yeah cuz then like metal gear solid
ground zero is because it's only thirty
bucks you won't get as high rating you
know because money equals x better game
reviews yeah and then we talked about
SimCity of course that was some fan
service and the fact that they they made
an offline mode for that it's similar
sort of way on the exact same day at
diablo 3's auction has has finally been
removed yeah the real money and the gold
auction houses both gone you know they
were they launched in 2012 they're gone
early 2014 so not a lot of time there
for it but they said i believe it was
last GDC that the auction houses
undermined the core gameplay is and that
is kill monsters get loot so if you
could buy things with real money that
was kind of against the spirit of their
game so yeah in a similar way they're
taking it out as you know if answer was
in response to what fans have said and
especially after they've patched the
game and basically remodel the entire
loot system or you know they probably
debase the market in terms of what was
in the auction s anyway because you
could kill self and get like really good
kiss that you couldn't before yeah the
folks who've been playing the the update
that's gone live to like precede reaper
souls have said like in an hour of play
they've just gotten like way better loot
than they did in 30 hours of play
earlier on is crazy so if you wanted to
play simcity you wanted to play diablo
and you were holding off it sounds like
now is a bread the right time to head
back into it eddie makuch thank you very
much for joining us you headin back onto
the GBC happy to be here yeah i'm headed
there right now pennell at three o'clock
so i'm running what panel is it what
panel is 0 second screen apps
or had like designing second screen apps
for Triple A games i'm going to go see
the assassins creed people with their
second screen smart waiting so i'm going
to see that on gamespot com then in a
couple of hours and white it up get your
write-ups done awesome okay boss I'm not
as boss as speaking of the album